blackrock the 10 trillion dollar asset
manager is going all in on bitcoin baby
yes this is what i'm talking about
blackrock the world's largest asset
manager is now going to offer bitcoin
trading to their clients now blackrock
isn't just any asset manager they're the
largest in the world let's look at how
big they actually are they have 10
trillion dollars in aum they've got over
16 000 employees and their clients are
large financial institutions corporate
pensions endowments family offices and
much much more they've already been
participating in the bitcoin and crypto
industry it's not just the first thing
they're doing they were trading the cme
bitcoin futures they have a plan to
launch an ishares blockchain and tech
etf and they already own more than 16
of microstrategy the publicly traded
company that owns a ton of bitcoin on
their balance sheet now ultimately what
this all shows us is that now we are
entering a point where if you work at a
wall street institution you're going to
big hedge fund if you work at an
institutional asset allocator you have
more career risk in not participating in
this industry than you do in actually
participating what do i mean well our
friend preston pish he described this
perfectly he said now that blackrock jpm
fidelity wells fargo and others are on
board with bitcoin the wall street sheep
are starting to develop career risk by
not being on board watching blackrock
capitulate and have to go further and
further into the bitcoin and crypto
industry it's sweet baby
all of these financial institutions on
wall street they realize what the
individuals on the internet realized
years ago
bitcoin is the most pure macro asset in
the world it protects your purchasing
power and ultimately it is the last free
market standing every single wall street
hedge fund financial institution bank
and asset allocator ultimately has to
participate the question is just when do
they realize it and how much punishment
do they take for waiting
i love watching blackrock get into the
market
ultimately this couldn't be more bullish
for the industry what people need to
watch is how quick blackrock's gonna go
from orange build to rolling out all
these products and services to as many
clients as possible blackrock loves
bitcoin and bitcoin will love blackrock